so today another record-setting day
today denise look at this 86 degrees or
high you kidding me for
for november the previous record was 85
set back in 1988 this may be
most likely our last 80 degree
temperature
until next year possibly march
centennial hill 68 degrees right now 65
for summerlin 66
for aliante the east side still coming
in in the mid 70s for
sunrise mountain i should say in nellis
green valley 77 71 henderson
road ranch and mountains edge both
coming in at 70. even elsewhere 78 death
valley 72 boulder city
laughlin near just shy of 80 degrees
right now and there's actually some
showers and storms out there mainly in
arizona flagstaff just north of phoenix
while we remain dry here
even some lightning strikes detected up
there
into utah but snow up there in reno and
tahoe with some
showers too this is all from that low
that's just spinning it's got a lot of
cold there along with it and it will be
diving to our area that's why our
temperatures will drop
that's why we'll see more wind again
tomorrow and this will also pivot the
chance of this
showers are possible for your saturday
but it will be very
isolated maybe scattered in some spots
but mainly isolated and we have a small
window
shower chances for tomorrow more
widespread chances though for sunday
snow levels will be dropping down to
5000 feet
above that we'll get some snow so expect
some snow in the mountains that's why
that winter storm watch goes into effect
on sunday night through monday morning
but after that after
sunday we're back to sunny skies but
cooler temperatures your wind profile
for tomorrow
a little breezy in the morning peaking
though late morning as that front starts
to slide through
we'll keep those gusts around 35 to even
40 in some spots
all the way into the afternoon before
they decrease tomorrow night so here's
your forecast 56 degrees overnight
gusty and cooler all under partly cloudy
skies your high for tomorrow 61 that's
25 degrees cooler
than today showers are slight chance for
tomorrow like we talked about
your gusts between 30 to 40 miles per
hour here are your neighborhood
temperatures remember
85 today 60 for north las vegas tomorrow
same goes for spring valley only 59
centennial hills 61 mountains edge 63
green valley
will be in those high 50's for prompt
and boulder city laflin will have a high
tomorrow
of 70 degrees now here's how it looks
for the next few days it's going to be
chilly on sunday with those shower
chances again so this weekend is when
all the weather is going to really be
happening
after that everything goes away but the
temperatures stay cool some 10 to 15
degrees cooler than normal
all through veterans day and into this
time next week
that's your most accurate forecast have
a great and safe weekend everyone